good afternoon first of all I want to
thank the organizers for giving me this
great opportunity to come up here and
talk about our work and today yes I want
to talk about communal comparative
networks network analysis how to
understand how protein interactions and
protein networks evolve speaking you
know evolution is a big theme in
biological research right you know a lot
of people have talked about even just
today here and I didn't want to go
through sort of because you know
sequencing of course you know it's the
first large-scale data that we have
biological data that we have and it
still is the most abundant data right
sequencing with next-gen sequel so you
know comparative genomics is you know
one of the approach people study
evolution and it's been really very very
important and continue to be important
but again I seen this same picture
actually this morning so shows the
stability of Google searches so anyway
but you know the point has been made
also by multiple speakers just even
today that you cannot even everything it
seems a sequence or eyes you have to
look at a network and so the next sort
of methods you know people have been
doing is comparative functional genomics
like again you know people have talked
about genetic networks and comparative
actually even comparative analysis of
genetic interaction networks which again
is very very important and continue to
be important but let me just say genetic
interaction is not a physical
physiological process in the cell right
so two genes can't imagine any action
for many reasons and also we into
comparisons it could be that there is a
genetic interaction that there or not
there because a gene lost a who then in
the copy in one of the species so that
can give you some interpretation
difficulties so what we really want to
do is we want to directly compare
function right so to speak comparative
function no mix right and the way we do
it is we want to look at interaction
how interactions evolve because number
one protein interaction protein for
interaction is protein function and
number two most proteins even
transcription factors have to bind other
cofactors right to carry out their
function so understanding interaction is
very very important to understand their
function so and this looking at the
evolution of protein interactions and
protein interaction networks is not a
new problem not at all right so people
have been trying to look at this
especially since you know for ten years
now people we have networks in east fly
humor and warm people have been trying
to do comparative analysis just for the
interaction network but again it's been
very useful but success has been very
very limited actually surprisingly just
because overlaps are very very sparse
between this network I remember one of
the first papers in Nature Genetics find
only 16 interactions are shared between
the four species right so you cannot do
any statistics using only 16 pairs so I
think the problem is none of these
networks are whole protein scale right
so not all the proteins they have even
tested and number two and I will get to
even more is that our technology we
realize have a huge false negative phos-
issue right so is we don't detect a lot
of the interactions right so even your
testing Iraq of protein not all the
interactors are found and also these are
huge result from e body needs to all of
these there you know 1.5 billion and
above years apart right so you really
need to have comprehensive maps at
appropriate evolutionary distance and
generated by the same technology again
people trying to do this comparison by
combine all the interactions in the
literature for other purposes that is
good because that improves your coverage
but the interaction in the literature
are detected by different as a
completely different assets kawaii p and
you know management all and they all
have different false positive and false
negative rates and i will show you where
later on you can
you know most of this actually almost
all of them you don't know as one of
speaker to talk about today so you
cannot plug them into the equation that
i'm going to show you you cannot
calculate them so we really need to use
the same technology and you know the
false positive or negative rates right
so my lab is really our systems biology
lab although I'm in the past electricity
permanent Cornell right so we do
experiments and our primary screen
methods is y 2h and I wanna you know I
know different people have different
opinions on y 2h so I just want to talk
a little bit about y 2h so we you know
first of all you know we have you know y
2h is really huge scale so we can do
1,000,000 protein pairs screened per
person per week so that's a scale that
none other method comes even close and
so we believe you know we published the
slough papers on this that y 2h at least
our version of the y tu age is actually
very high quality and i will show you
more data hopefully can convince you and
also the problem really is you know
we've realizes for more than 10 years
now bye you know like the effort led by
actually my postdoc like mark of it all
at hover he realized that at the early
on thur softener network the early the y
2h a networking yeast are all done a lot
of those are done by using a cDNA
library so that you know there's a whole
host of other reasons but using CD in
libraries is very dangerous because we
realize so what we do is we use or calls
over each team we generate a specific
clone one clone and we sequence verified
so we know the sequence is right and we
tested and then the the reason for why
do is it through this watchu h process
because it's a very harsh selection
right so it's a life-and-death selection
so proteins that don't mean her act if
you've two proteins don't interact the
cell dies that's that's just very simple
so so wants to live right so it's
evolution so we realize oftentimes
proteins that don't interact under
normal actually don't interact will
accumulations so that they can interact
that they can surviving are
so to get rid of that what we do is
after the screen we go back to a frozen
copy of those combs and we retest them
and we actually by doing that we get rid
of half of our heads it's actually a
huge loss but we would want to have that
so that i can report double the size of
the network so but you see the if you'll
see in library because you don't have a
life you don't have a specific library
for each gene you can't do that so you
cannot do the end also the
representation in sydney in libraries is
dictated by the expression levels in the
cell right so that has a huge bias so
creates all kinds of problems and
there's mother things that you know
we've developed so we believe our burden
is very very good in fact if you go back
to the joseph of the network and the
early why 28 East network one practice
and we've decided not to do anymore is
they always report a corset and an
encore set for the early East for
example the nature two thousand paper it
was a course that is 800 interactions
which is solid and then they have a nun
corset is a three thousand erections and
the difference between the two diff data
set is how many times they see it in
their screen and the fact that three
thousand is they don't see it again they
only see the one time so the fact that i
only see the one time country you know
so if you get rid of that 800 we have
actually tested using independent essays
to show is actually pretty good quality
yes the second the second time to do it
and it's not positive then you throw it
out yes so how much you you how many
positives are you losing better than a
half so for ya so for ya half half yeah
so fifty percent chance we use also very
restrict you know very stringent where
stringent criteria as I mean it depends
also because of we do the second screen
sort of first time around we we can go a
little bit sort of the threat will can
be a little bit lower and then we use
the second threat or higher so but the
way we do it we lose half I mean I would
definitely want to keep that as an
encore so that we can report a bigger
number but we don't do that it's gone
using that you wouldn't want to live oh
that I will show you I will show you
that we do we lose a lot yes i will show
you that kind of yeah so that the false
negative rate you're getting too yeah so
anyway so let me hopefully yeah so
hopefully I can go through the top
anyway so so you know you know as
opposed to act so I've been fortunate to
be involved in these two net worth of
buddies and the human but he's still the
most the only protein scale screens that
we've ever done in eukaryotes and my
humans actually mark just published a
cell paper about a year ago so that
becomes the most comprehensive anyway so
so we want it because we did this funny
East so we want to do we need to do a
well-controlled systematic cross-species
interaction comparison and we decided to
use punky because it's much closer it's
related East species to budding yeast
and so we want to do this kind of
comparison and war fume is already
available so we don't have to spend
years to just clone these 500 proteins
from the pommy genome so my talk today I
want to talk about first just we build
the first protein why network for
fission yeast and the biological inside
so I really want to show you guys this
we get from that and then the second
part is comparative network analysis and
we did to show you Volusia nary insights
right so we did it so they have there's
5,000 proteins right we screen 5,000 by
five thousand three times so that's 75
million pairs tested and we found only
really it's not even so the reward is
wearing so it's 2300 interactions for
1300 proteins so we throw out a lot but
if you look at this you actually covers
a wide range of different cellular
processes and about half of it is novel
if never reported in any other species
before and 700 of those novel involves
orthologs in humans so it can really
tells you human biology right so of
course the first question is
published a couple months ago so we're
very happy and you know about quality so
one thing we show so the way we do this
is we pick a large positive controls set
and a large random pairs as our negative
control set right and we test first we
test the work a white wage and you can
see so our work again our version of why
28 is actually does not suffer through
high false-positive rate at all we
didn't detect any from those random
pairs so but the problem really is from
about a hundred you know multiple lab
independently validated interactions we
were only able to find a pack you know a
little bit more than twenty percent so
we eighty percent of the interactions
out there even if we test it we won't
find it so that is really the problem so
that's really a problem that's for any
other essays wrestle so we have the
sufficient net we call this fish in net
and so to test it we use another
independent essay right so it has
nothing to do with a white wage which is
the pc is protein complementation sa
basically you have two fragments of the
yfp you fuse that with your protein into
as x and y and if X of Y interact you
reconstitute a functional yfp right and
this is done in mammalian cells so
completely has nothing to do with ES
cells and you can see again that also
has sort of sensitivity issues right and
but when we tested using this component
appended methods we show our fish in
that and the positive controls are the
same quality but also in any of these
networks we all know there is Hobbs
right biologists often say all these
house maybe tend to be more noisy that
is also not the case either and we find
the same quality so okay so that really
shows systematically that we have a good
quality but really can we learn new
biology right from this network so and
the way so we sort of picked this
example which is Hitchcock gene
regulation by ATF one so if you have one
pines constitutively to all of the
atf one is the major regulator
transcription factor in fission ease
regulating all the heat shock jeans but
ATF one constitutionally buying to all
of the promoters of the heat shock jeans
even under normal conditions right so
there is a question of the control so
just a couple years ago there's a paper
published saying they didn't find any
physical link but they found that dieser
one somehow is involved in these heat
shock genes they say that nicer one
involves in repression of these heat
shock jeans under normal conditions and
then under he shocked i saw one is
transported outside of the nucleus and
relieved of the repression and therefore
these key shark teens can respond to
heat stress but they found no physical
link so well let's just so the reason so
we pick this example it's not as very
actually systematic because we want to
find new biology we want to find biology
that using really show the power of an
interactive network right so we want to
find we want to follow up on
interactions that connects to well
studied pathways and modules so we did
clustering and we look at connecting da
way interactions never seen before
connecting to well study the modules
right so not that many actually we we
found so this is one of this so on one
hand you have stress response all these
interactions found by y2h and has been
studied to death in the literature so
people knows that i wanna regulate atf
one in all of these and on the other
hand is the RDR see complex that
involves you RNAi pathways are without
boring with this involved in the gene
silencing at the centromere region okay
it's a major player in there and all
again we found these interactions you
watch wage and this complex is well
established before us but this
interaction has never been shown before
right so our hypothesis is all since
this paper didn't find a physical link
epic out between dice or one on this and
this complex actually turns nascent
single strand RNA into double strand RNA
provide substrate for dyson one that's
what only works with double stranded RNA
so we say oh maybe this is the physical
link this is where
atf one can recruit the army I machinery
to their heat shakti in target regions
which has really cool never been shown
before in vivo so this is our hypothesis
first of course we did because our white
weight is done in budding yeast cells
right these are fitting these proteins
but we do with the white which is done
but it's always okay does it even happen
in vivo so we show you how I p infinity
vivo quality shows this interaction does
happen in vivo in kitchen in cells and
we also show to do this kind of look at
the MRA levity pressure levels we show
that delete dieser one you relief right
when you in normal conditions ty sir one
is required to repress this jean de
penser one gene expression increases
same thing if you delete c12 also
increases but double division you don't
increase anymore I mean you know
significantly so shows Dyson 1c 12 is
working the same pathway for this
purpose right and then I want to go one
step further my student really hate me
for this race I said okay if we're
convinced this is the physical link
because it's the only link we could find
in our network and in the literature to
link this to powerful army I and this ap
f1 heat shock deregulation if this is
only the real link if we break this link
which would be able to separate these
two pathways right so and another part
of my lab is to do these kind of using
structural modeling and others to model
mutation effects right so I told the
students can you come up with three
candidates I'll sit 12 that specific
losing erection was a shin one but still
pines rd p 1 HR 1 keep the integrity of
our dr see it look at me son you know
it's not gonna work right i said well
let's just try it so we came up with two
he came up using her a preliminary sort
of a pipeline three mutations along
behold two of them work exactly as we
have predicted right as a brick
specifically this interaction atf 1c 12
but keeps the integrity of the RDR see
complex right the third one doesn't have
any fat
so again so here we show the heat-shock
deregulation you know this so these two
mutants do they still can regulate heat
shock jeans right basically we show that
you know in the CEO of deletion strength
these jeans are overexpressed if you
overexpress wild-type c12 in the c12
divisions to end of course you rescue
that right so these scenes level goes
back down but if you overexpress these
to point a shin they do not have the
ability to regulate those heat shock
jeans anymore either keep highly
expressed so that's really cool shows
that okay if you lose this interaction
you lose this regulation again shows
this is the recruitment point right so
what about the RDR ceased function as
rei pathway factor right what about the
centromere silencing so basically there
is a string that has been developed by
another lab who is graciously shared
with us and so basically you sort of
your you're a 4 reporter into the
centromere and so in regular under
normal conditions centromere region no
gene is expressed or you are four is not
expressed and if you are four is not
expressed the cells are not sensitive to
five fo oasis and reverse selection
right so under normal conditions if you
just express a vector is equal but if
you delete seat 12 centromere is
expressed because it's required rei is
required so that the cell are become
very sensitive to father for way if you
overexpress us what well type c 12 in
the cell seeker of deletion you rescue
sign right so they can grow again and
when we overexpress the two point
mutations behaves just like the
wild-type at the centromere reason right
so that we show by creating a point
mutation specifically disrupt this
interaction we can separate our a
sequence function as the heat-shock teen
lucas a low sigh and at the central near
locust so it's really very cool as a
shows that our theory is a tf1 recruit
physically binds and recruits the RDR
see
complex to this he jumped in low side
and no basically recruit the whole army
i passed away to these low sighs and you
know under normal conditions shut down
the expression of these he shot teens
and he can we have different theory but
you know this is the publication of that
paper is the heat will dislocate the
dyson one out of the loca out of the
nucleus and then relief of these he
charging can be expressed under heat
stress right so we call this sort of
acted transcription activator
recruitment of RNA I car 14 silencing
right so we were quite excited about
this so and I just want to say so this
is basically the first part we actually
have about five or six example like this
all find use my criteria looking for
connections between known pathways and
you know they are all validated and we
didn't test that many to get to those
five or six examples we only tested no
more than ten examples we start with so
the hit rate is where I means much
higher than I thought so I really think
these networks are can be very helpful
if you use it correctly and then so now
we have this network can we compare it
to the bunnies and the human network
right so we have the three networks the
one question we want to know is oh how
you know everybody asked this right how
is the interactions are conserved how
many interactions are conserved between
the species right and many publications
has published looking at this question
of course very to do this people say oh
it's easy you take the interactions to
2300 interactions the efficient ease you
look at how many of them are inhuman how
many of them in budding yeast that is
your conservation rate but that's not
right right because we know that eighty
percent of the real international
network none of these networks are
completely right there are actually
eighty percent incomplete so you can't
just do that directly write like another
speaker also earlier talked about it so
you really need to
but a lot of paper has published that
way and so anyway so really what we want
to get the conservation way really it
sort of this probability right is if you
have interaction in a species to what is
not sort of our observed so if you just
do this direct overlap the that fraction
really is the probability of you observe
an interaction in species 2 x y 2h in
species one that is the problem that is
not the conservation ring right but you
can actually expand this right this way
and now this is your kinds of underlying
conservation rain right is interaction
in species to also interaction in
species one but that is that really the
conservation really want to get so and
it turns out so we just need to you know
calculation we have this this is the
observed conservation rate if you wish
and we want to get to that we just need
to be able to measure or estimate these
things right so turns out we can
estimate that right so for that for
example if we make this I think it's a
very reasonable assumption is if I have
an interaction in species one the
probability of i detecting that
interaction in species one really
doesn't have anything to do with whether
it's going to have its interacting in
another species right it's just so if i
make that assumption and also when I
know that the conservation weight is or
the rewiring wait interacting species to
not interacting species why just one
minus this right so this is very simple
we can actually solve this right this is
our true conservation rate this is our
observed conservation rate and these are
just basically false positive and false
negative rates of Y 218 these species
and we can measure all of these using
the positive and negative controls so we
solve this and we can even estimate the
error in our asking pain using delta
methods right so can do all of this so
we can actually very so and we did that
right so we did that but before I show
you the concert with interaction
conservation rate I just want to remind
you this is basic the gene conservation
rate or genomic sequence similarity in
relation
chef or evilution or a relationship
between species right clearly the two
yeasts a much more related eighty
percent of the genes are shared between
the two species and they are further
there they're both further away from
human only I think sixty percent or
fifty five percent of genes are shared
between human either East's right so
human is the out group here based on a
sequence so first calculate this palm be
conserved interactions in bunny East we
got about forty percent its point is one
point we don't know what to make of this
next we look at Palm Beach to human
remember these conservation ways are
actually directional ok so so pumping
her actions seventy percent of them will
be conserving humans so much higher than
call me in budding is that's so we used
multiple things to look at the ortho or
authority is basically use in paranoid
we use in parallel we also have you know
palm base for example for palm and human
palm and budding is we always take the
community consider oh yes so for this
calculation I'm pretty sure so yeah
review also reads that question yes so
we did so this one we just compare we
just consider all of them but there is
one figure it's the same exact figure
where we only use the one two one two
one two one worth lakhs so that there's
no question of multiple mapping yes so
that's a good question and so sure
that's okay it's not surprising and then
we look at burning is to human also
seventy percent but it is the pump call
me also seventy percent human to pound
me seventy percent but human tu servicio
gang goes down to you know forty five
percent right so basically based on this
our explanation is that basically so
paninis is a very good model reason what
you learned
can be equally well you know applied to
human as well as fission yeast however
there are functions like the Army I we
talked about you just cannot study so
there's a lot of interactions has been
lost or functions has been lost in
budding yeast so so to study those you
have to use fisheries but whatever you
learn in budding is is is actually
pretty good right so you know so many
functions shared between fittings and
human bellossom putting these rights
such as army I we know but he's doesn't
have our own yard so oh so all right so
speaking of the silvas conservation so
speaking of conservation actually I tend
to think there's this sort of paradox so
to speak that is whenever we talk about
conservation conservation especially in
comparative genomics right have a sense
of not change concern means is not
change and in comparative genomics we
look at sequences literally means the
sequence is not changed right however we
also know that many proteins even if
they have conserving your actions they
evolve new interaction that carry out
the novel functions right in the new
species that's being repurposed to a two
degree they keep their old function but
they also have new function so what is
that all about so because we have all
these clones right so we can literally
passed perform which I'm very excited
about these cross-species mappings right
so we can take basic we can ask right we
know a B and I e prime B prime are
conserving your actions in the two
species what about if I test a sibility
to buying be prime and I ain't prongs
ability to bind be right like I said all
these species separated by hundreds of
millions years and billions of years or
so this is basically like a date
billions of years in the making right so
I'm very excited about this so we did
this we did all of these and then so if
they still keep interaction this is you
mean that means that the interface
between a and B has been kept for the
billion-year but if they don't means
that they have cold wall even though the
interaction is
served the interface has coeval has
changed so they cannot recognize their
partner from a billion years ago and if
you really think about it you know in
evolution apart because Cohen deliver
you you need the two proteins to change
coordinate lane right so it's very I
mean if we think about it's not easy at
all right so and we don't have a lot of
exactly do have example but don't have a
lot of examples of co-evolved
interaction Parliament between species
right so my expectation is this should
be relatively rare but that's actually
not what happened here we found actually
almost half of the concern interactions
for both the East pair and fitting is to
human has been the conservator action
has been calling ball right and that
actually agrees with our human work and
other people have shown this is to
rewind to change the interaction
interface one mutation oftentimes is
enough to do it right so so even though
at the amino acid for a given pair it's
very hard to co-evolved but the proteins
large and interface is large right so
you're only need one pair often times
it's enough to change the interfacing
enough so that the Ocelot cannot
recognize it anymore right so that's
actually really interesting and that
explains like how they can potentially
these have at least can potentially now
accommodate the new interface and so
this is an example where so these web
112 and cdc 43 are three suddenly the
farnesyltransferase in subunits three
subunits of foreign source transfer is
in in the bunny east and it's very
important for post translational
modification of proteins in cell cycle
control people know that and you can see
we recognize in her actions work very
well in our hands the pong be ones also
working our hand but the cross-species
wants none of them work right so good oh
alright so sure and we found this and we
look at the literature we realize people
have actually done the budding in up
because there's so many studies in
Bonnie's people have done this study
they show that if you meet run to and
you're over expert you how
did the defects over USC wp1 the
ortholog officially it does not rescue
right so I mean we saw perfectly
explains their observation so which is
really cool so this is an example of so
well I don't have time but i just want
to show that we can also use this to
really study gene duplication right
because gene duplicated really is a
major source of genetic novelty through
evolution and all vertebrates has get
gone through at least two round of whole
genome duplication and the small-scale
point duplication is continuous right so
and I just yeah anyway so I don't have
time to go through this but basically
there has been a lot of studies about
you know what happens after gene
duplication right of course at the very
beginning is functional redundancy
because you have two identical copies
but then you could have sub
functionalization versus neon
functionalization so far people you know
either rabid offices or in yeast because
you only have one correct home they
often just look at how many interactions
are shared between paralogs which gets
to the point of functional redundancy
really there is no experimental data
about some function the degree to which
you have self organization and new
functionalization and we know bunning is
has become through a whole genome
duplication but they also have course
sort of point and team specific
duplications so we can now and we have
the fission yeast so we can use
basically the 50s as outgroup to get
about the sub function ization and the
new function as a I don't have time to
go through them but basically we show
that whole genome duplication lead to
more functional redundancy we believe
and there's a literature support that
the stoichiometry comes into play
because everything is duplicated versus
small-scale gene-specific or segment
duplications lead to more sort of
genetic anomaly if you wish more sub for
organization and/or neo
functionalization and i think you know
that can have a major impact because all
vertebrates as I said come through these
so basically just to summarize we've
done this network what believe is high
quality I
us to find a couple of new gene
regulation factors actually rei and i'm
already splicing and also can help us to
do comparative network analysis and you
know all the work done by my students
and technicians and postdocs and my
collaborators and my funding agencies
and thank you thank you so much please
when you pin your network you have this
initial screen which was quite literal
and then you have second screen which
perhaps understand was little bit for
some of it was independent and then was
more stringent have you been ever
tempted to the independent second screen
and to compare you know what yes yes so
we have done it at mark where I got
trained as opposed to also have done it
so there is very very very consistent
yeah so you do how yes very very
consistent yeah once you do that is very
very consistent it's very very tense I
don't know yeah yeah side of the force
I so the error estimation will be
depending on your right but that
specific that the conservation rate is
not right because the error is because
that ties into if we test a hundred
pairs versus in our ghost and reversals
we have a thousand parroting our
standards our error estimation will be
different the thousand pairs can give us
a more better error estimation but the
estimation of the conservation rate is
not depend on the pair on the size of
the gold standard when we use a smaller
portion of what we know it that would be
great because as I said our gold
standard so there are two things number
one is fit knees it's really the
Forgotten East I have to say right so
you know you might grind up application
actually I wrote that is you have you
know I won't begin this you have about
80,000 high quality binary direct
interactions reported by all kinds of
resources in the literature just go to
any database in buddy nice but in pongy
only at time that five years ago is 142
I'd remember in feature knees so i cant
yeah it's not like i have a thousand so
that i can do that i would love and also
that's one reason i just don't have that
many also these experiments are not as
easy as a six cell as a sequencing so
we're trying to develop methods as well
so these are still pretty tedious to do
to do that but that would be interesting
to look at please
the ones that cool you off from the ones
that remain consistent like when you
prostate them they still find um yeah
based on the experiments we can help did
you find any features we haven't looked
into that yet and that's something we
can I mean I think or one thing we
didn't notice is the interface
conservation so oh I didn't have time so
we didn't look into that a little so
interface for example the conservation
is much better between this intact
versus I mean that's that's almost a
given right because so they're just and
actually one thing I didn't show is
actually it's interesting is that for
those intact interactions so between the
fish knees and human we can actually
clone me and so we know because mark and
you know I we've done a lot of these and
Mary Ann we've done allow these condom
you tation these imitation for the human
proteins look at whether they how they
disrupt interactions we comb the same
human mutation into the fission yeast
protein the same examination and if it's
true out the same exact set of
interactions in fittings for those
impact ones for the required ones we
can't even find a lot because they don't
even a lie anymore yeah so it's actually
pretty cool by the results on the
conservation between the species okay
the two yeast are not as concerned as
Eastern unit you find the support in the
graphs yes in terms of the interaction
conservation yes could it be that
because the human network is much bigger
then somehow your estimates were by but
even with the human ones it's the how
would that bias I didn't see because we
do the same comparison so we have the
proficiencies the human and human 250
knees and fittings do bunnies to human
than human bodies I don't see how they
so that is a concern so we look at it
the detection rate are the same in all
these species from the false positive or
negative rates using positive negative
control sets in this species we have
three sets of positive or negative
controls they all behaving very
similarly yeah
key rating us and saying that the twists
are very close that's why sure yeah so
yeah so that's so that's so for the
that's also was something of a debate
actually yeah so there is people believe
so basic the estimation is 400-year
million years 21 billion years depends
on who you talk to you the more genetic
molecular biology Park MSHA people
believe there are 400,000 very close you
don't need to study fission yeast if you
understand everything in budding yeast
it's the same in fittings but if you'd
have to evolutionary biologists they
believe it's like a billion years apart
there as far away as humor and east so
there is this difference of opinion but
regardless I think it's just what we saw
I mean this is the result what we saw in
the explainer we can come well come up
with to fit that you know like a
parsimony explination is just that
there's a lot of interactions that are
shared between human and fission yeast
that are simply lost like REI which we
know in the bunny needs to mean eh I
think we should we should we should take
it